I said dad I remember when you when we
were growing up you said you know I
moved to America with 12 dollars in my
pocket and and I really wanted to you
know start a better life for everybody
but I also know that I'm an actor and I
exaggerated everything because that's
literally I don't know what you were
referring that account so I called him I
said I just want to make sure I'm not
exaggerating you moved to America with
12 dollars in your pocket right and he
very understand it he goes I'm afraid
you are exaggerating
when I moved to America I had eight
dollars in my pocket but the point is
yeah they were they worked incredibly
hard it's been some incredible
challenges there were a lot of
challenges and I can tell you they did
not move to America for me to be an
actor which I think was the point to
tell you that but they're so supportive
now and I think part of it is you for
any parent really if hey if you don't
know that that's an actual career and a
lot of places around the world that's
you know the arts are not a career
there's not a commercial sector for the
arts it's scary right you want your kids
to have stability the arts are not
stable knock on wouldn't be very
fortunate a few years but you never know
so Johnson it's like this yeah yeah at
every level right yeah agreed agreed
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this